hi Leute willkommen zu vlogmas Tag
Nummer 9 wir sind auf dem Weg von
Mailand nach zermat in die Schweiz wir
wollen Skifahren gehen ich habe ja
skiahren geübt und heute fahren wir hin
und ich glaube die Zugfahrt wird richtig
schön der Bahnhof ist sehr groß erinnert
mich ein bisschen an der Bahnhof in
Stuttgart ne und das Gebäude sah auch
einfach schon wieder aus wie eine
Sehenswürdigkeit ohne Witz dann suchen
wir jetzt mal kurz unseren Zug und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder das Problem
ist die Zahlen werden immer höher und
wir brauchen aber die vier ja wir sind
in Gleis vier Zug Nummer vi vielleicht
ab dem neuen Zug droppen sie das ist in
Deutschland doch auch manchmal so dass
du hohe Zahlen hast und plzlich komm
Italia guck das ist unser
Zug schen wir mal ja Zug ein du musst
machen Timo du musst lockm machen zu vi
wir sind da wir sind da oh mein
Gott okay Hardcore heavy shit Leute wir
sind im Zug drin mein Sitz kaputt soll
so nee guck mal wie meiner nach vorne
rutscht ist noch weiter als deiner aber
wir haben es geschafft wir sitzen im Zug
das ist schon mal sehr gut wir sitzen am
Fenster wir hoffen auf eine schöne
Aussicht ich glaube es kommt eine
richtig schöne Aussicht irgendwie habe
ich das im Gefühl dass wir so richtig
schöne Berge und sowas sehen werden und
die Fahrt dauert auch gar nicht so lange
eine Stunde 50 ich habe unsere
Zugtickets für die Schweiz wo wir
umsteigen schon gescreenshottet weil wir
in der Schweiz ja kein Internet haben in
Europa habe ich noch ganz normal
Internet das gehört zu meinem Ding dazu
aber vielleicht habe ich ja auch Schweiz
vielleicht ist das ja so Europa und
Schweiz aber ich glaube nicht und das
wird erstmal hart ich meine wenn wir
dann erstmal in zerat sind zermat ist
nicht groß da können wir einfach zu
unserem Hotel laufen ich glaube da
gibt's sogar so ein Tunnel von unser vom
Bahnhof zu unserem Hotel deswegen das
wird einfach aber ja bye bye Milano du
warst
beautiful Vergleich deutsche Bahnsystem
Vers italienische Bahnsystem wie ratest
du wie rankst du sie man merkt halt dass
dieser Bahnhof ser alt ist ne aber hier
ist alles halt sehr alt das einzige was
ich jetzt komisch fand war dass unser
Gleis nicht angezeigt wurde bis 20 vor
also die zeigen das Gleis von wo dein
Zug abfährt halt relativ spät an aber
ansonsten war es okay ich glaube man
muss nur echt pünktlich da sein wenn man
an einem Fremden Bahnhof ist deswegen
waren wir jetzt auch so eine halbe
Stunde vorher da weil man einfach ja
überhaupt nicht klar kommt und erstmal
gucken muss wo was ist bin auch auf die
falsche Seite vom Gleis gelaufen direkt
Panik bekommen ich so h wo ist sie no
ein paar Schnittbilder gemacht habe vom
Bahnhof und dich nicht mehr gefunden
habe und ich war mir ganze Zeit so
sicher dass du hinter mir bist deswegen
ich bin ganze so gelaufen nicht so na ja
wahrscheinlich filmt er mich gerade von
hinten wie wir hier lang laaufen und so
und irgendwannbrt meine Tasche wo bist
du ja guck mal das Mailand sieht nicht
so schön aus ne wir melden uns dann
wieder zurück wenn die Aussicht ein
bisschen schöner ist hier sehen Sie
einen großen See oh ja jetzt sieht man
ihn noch ein bisschen der ist wirklich
sehr groß ich löse gerade meine Rätsel
aus meinem
rätseladventskalender und Timo spielt
mit seiner Steam Deck
tolle Bahnfahrt wie zwei Kinder
oh
schön hier kommen die Hügel immer auf
der Jagd nach dem nächsten
shot dort hinten wow schaut
mal boah guck mal Timo Timo diese Inseln
es wird einfach eine wow Compilation wow
wow wow oh da oben sind sogar
Wolken wow diese Gebäude hier ist ein
richtig Alter
Ort ich reagiere ganze Zeit ganz krass
auf alles was ich sehe te und nicht so
weil Timo das schon alles kennt ich war
noch nie in den Bergen ich kenne das
nicht für mich ist das alles gerade
komplett neu mega cool aber sieht schon
immer noch episch aus ja
kleinen Dörfchen hier auch ja so
schnucklig aus irgendwie also man sieht
aber keine Menschenseele das
bissuselig sind nur Häuser
wow wow
[Musik]
wow das ist ein Jump pass gut
auf
what und was sagst du
wir sind nicht mal Final Destination
sieht schon geil aus ne wir sind erst
jetzt in Brick wir sind noch nicht mal
ins zmat die Luft ist ein bisschen
dünner hier oder ich kann kaum mehr
atmen
thumbnail Ich sehe zum ersten Mal die
Berge insane ich bin
[Musik]
sprachlos das ist eigentlich unsere
Abfahrt ich verstehe gerade gar nichts
unser fährt um
1357 ja das ist der eere 42 1357 fährt
nach genevev Airport aber nicht nach
zemat nach zemat fährt erst um
14:52 27 ja warum ja gut wir nehmen den
nach ZAT das muss dann irgendwie steht
auch re42 dran bei dir auf der Ticket
re241 steht da wir haben Tickets gekauft
für
1357 nach zermat ja und jetzt steht da
also jetzt glauben wir dass es 1427 ist
nach zermat genau und aber 13:57 uh das
ist einfach mit Umsteigen in FIS ach so
weil sie haben ein sparbillet gekauft
sie Ken nur der Zug benutzen den Sie
gebucht haben
ah ung super
danke hätten wir gleich Stress gehabt am
Anfang ja ich habe ich habe das
sparbillet gekauft ich habe das billige
Ticket gekauft das wollte sie mir damit
noch sagen unser Zug in dem ihr saßen
ist auch nach WISP gefahren wir hätten
einfach nur sitzen bleiben sollen nein
doch nein aber ich habe ich mein ich
habe von Brick
gebucht
[Musik]
GLE gleich 6 an und müssen dann gleich
rüber zu Gleis 3
okay ganz schnell wir haben 5 Minuten
Zeit
kriegen ich glaub auch nicht dass der
Bahnhof so groß sein wird 4 Minuten
Umsteigezeit haben wir nur noch die Dame
war wenigstens so nett und hat uns hier
die Verbindung ausgedruckt ja bringt uns
nichts wenn nicht fährt wie es die
Verbindung sagt ne haben wir von der
Schweiz mehr erwartet ich h auf ich ma
mich nicht nervös die wissen ja auch
dass dieser Zug kommt und was man
umsteigen muss das muss ja irgendwie
funktionieren ist das da
wirklich ich kann das nicht glauben D
einfach Häuser sind dass da Leute leben
die Schweiz nutzt auch die Berge ne das
muss man auf jeden Fall sagen Küche
plätli Bad was ist plätli
Möbel
nervös
kurz Krien sind wir am Arsch man kommt
nur mit
man kommt da nicht anders hin das ist
eine
autofreiadt bitte lieber da müssen wir
zurück nach Brick und dann den
Zug schaffen wir wir schaffen das ne wir
schaffen das so mit in den Bergen so wir
sind
da okay was haben wir gelernt wir sind
bei Gleis 6 wir müssen zu Gleis 3 wir
müssen zu Gleis 3 wir müssen zugleich
schnelle mchen ne s eine schnelle
mischen alter
Schwede
wieso hab
ich
ich sag's
ehrlich wir sind die ganze Zeit nur am
stauen ich glaube die Leute um uns rum
denken dass wir noch nie Berge gesehen
haben was ja in meinem Fall richtig ist
in deinem Fall nicht so aber ich meine
gut so wir fahren jetzt erstmal und dann
melden wir uns wenn wir aussteigen gell
[Musik]
korrekt
Leute wir haben kein Internet in der
Schweiz weil wir natürlich so ein
Anbieter nicht haben aber wir haben
jetzt eine Karte bekommen bei der
Touristeninfo wir müssen so so so so
laufen und wir fahren sogar mit dem Lift
müssen wir zu unserem
Hotel unser Hotel so weit oben ist komm
Touristenführerin vanessa ist am Start
ich fühle mich als ob es wieder 1990 wä
nur die blöden lassen sich hier von den
Taxis abholen wir laufen zu Fuß das sind
auch alles hier hier fährt nichts mit
Benzin hier fährt alles eh
Timo wir sind noch auf
Kurs ich will darauf und schneeäel
machen aber erstmal unseren Schmerz er
okay wir die Luft ist hier irgendwie
auch laufen die Kamera okay muss do
laufen da se ich auch schon aquaröchen
trinken oh mein Gott da sehe ich uns
auch scheiß mal auf kein Alkohol oh das
großer Bus
hier wir müssen über diese Brücke hier
rüber da Tunnel wo wir zum Hotel kommen
kannst es dir ausmen wir suchen den
Tunnel wo wir zum Hotel kommen da ist
das Abri
wegen dem Nebel sieht man das ja gar
nicht aber wir sind komplett umgeben von
Bergen hte you da müssen wir
rein
da ja ich glaub
schon
hallo willst du mich verarschen
[Musik]
hallo das ist einfach unser Weg zum
Hotel die brauchen wir nicht
mehr
hammer
hammer reception ja
reception noch erlebt KR Tunnel in H
rein super krank ey wir sind so
glücklich
den sehen wir von unserem Zimmer aber
nicht in Gold wer weiß heute weiß so
wie immerch Berg
wärek
you thank you danke
schön wir sind wir sind das
höchste
was heißt Set
klingt
positiv
gut Master ich GLB allesim Master
sior
Master sieht das niedlich
a wir haben fucking
Kamin oh mein Gott oh mein Gott mein
Gott das ist nur die erste
Etage das ist
[Musik]
Timo was habe ich gebucht das ist nicht
sponsort das ist nicht spons wir haben
ein
Balkon oh
mein lie Timo un uns sweet ist oben das
ist nur der Kamin wir können uns ein
Feuer machen wir machen uns oh mein Gott
oh mann wir müssen unser stay hier
verlängern wir skippen Basel skenasel
wir könnten Basel skippen aber hier ist
wahrscheinlich alles
ausgebucht leck mich
doch ist das aber auch gemütlich
[Musik]
Co das ist so gemütlich und cozy ja und
da hätten wir eigentlich das ist
eigentlich der
mathorn aber der ist jetzt nicht
da
das cool oh mein Gott wie
cool Horn wenn man ihn sehen würde oh
mein Gott oh mein Gott oh mein Gott oh
mein Gott oh mein Gott oh mein Gott
krank oder das ist so heftig Scheiße wir
hätten hier zwei Wochen buchen sollen
Timo warst du so schm im Skiurlaub
absolut nicht nein komplett ist
krank komplett
insan ja schön schön
hier ich weiß auf jeden Fall wo ich
meinen Kaffee trinken
werde hallo und herzlich willkommen in
unserer unserem kleinen
JAL wir haben einen Gruß des Hauses
bekommen das testen wir natürlich hier
wieder
zuerst
magarons da essen wir ein ne du hast do
Hunger du Karamel auf jeden
Fall lecker lecker
alteramell ist richtig heftig und auch
probieren Karamell ist richtig
heftig oh mein Gott auch so happy
ne es ist so schön was ihr noch nicht
mitbekommen habt sobald wir hier drin
waren haben te und ich darüber geredet
ob wir nicht vielleicht hier bleiben
wollen und nicht nach Basel fahren da
ist zwar der schönste Weihnachtsmarkt
Europas den wir sehr gerne besuchen
wollen aber es wird regnen deswegen und
hier Schneid und hier ist gemütlich hier
kann man Skifahren hier kann man Rodeln
vielleicht okay darauf stoßen wir stoßen
erstmal uns Ankunft an oder würde ich
sagen wir stoßen auf uns paar
wundervolle Tage auf darauf dass du heil
den Berg runterkommst morgen oh ja m da
dürfen wir nicht zu viele Champagner
trinken aber so ein paar sind okay
oh mein Gott ich freue mich so wir
müssen aufhen das ist ein einziges seit
wir los sind war so wow wow wow die
sieht sehr viel größer aus wenn sie da
drin ist wenn sie rauskommt ist es so
süß na klar das ist Champagner kein
Proseco Leute damit würde ich sagen oh
die Leute schauen vielleicht das Video
vom
Hotel damit würde ich sagen auf Winter
auf zermat auf das Relais Chateau schön
Eck n sponsort ich glaube wir haben
sogar eine Dreherlaubnis hier überall zu
drehen aber das fragen wir noch mal in
der Reservation und Prost
hello so kling
Gewinner
e ich bin so hyped auf die kommenden
Tage es wird einfach so so geil und ich
würde sagen darauf Stoß mir mal an mein
Schatz auf uns auf uns unsere kleine
verlobungsreise
hier der schmeckt sogar noch gut okay
wir sollten auch ein bisschen Wasser
trinken wir haben sehr viel wenig
getrunken heute auf der Fahrt wir gehen
jetzt skisen mal ausleihen damit wir
morgen früh gleich am Start sind so
Leute der Tag ist
vorbei was für ein Tag was für eine
Woche Tim und ich müssen uns die ganze
Zeit so gegenseitig kneifen damit wir
checken dass es gerade auch echt was
passiert aber ansonsten geht's uns gut
ich ma mich jetzt fertig mit den jepoda
Minis und ich sag euch der
kaumbaum kennt ihr diese bahnhaut also
wenn ihr so lange in der Bahn SA und
lang unterwegs wart dass ihr dann so
richtig den Tag auf eurem Gesicht fühlt
jetzt nehme ich ihn einmal runter und
dann sieht man kurz aus wie ein
waschbeer ist aber völlig in Ordnung
jetzt kommt der beste Teil mit einem
warmen Handtuch aufs Gesicht mit Double
cleansing erreiche ich jetzt eine
porentiefe Reinigung und sanft wird auch
noch die Haut dazu gepielt abwaschen
probiert die Produkte von jepoda
unbedingt mal selber aus wie z.B den
repair
Hero und ich habe es schon h mal gesagt
midnight Magic die lavendelcreme für die
Nacht wenn ich nicht so müde wä dann wä
ich es jetzt und übrigens wenn ich euch
jetzt Lust auf die Produkte von jpoder
gemacht habe wie z.B den cbaum den ich
wirklich sehr empfehlen kann dann könnt
ihr jetzt meinen Rabattcode benutzen
malwanne für 20% Rabatt in der Infobox
findet ihr den Link viel Spaß mit eurer
Korean skincare Routine
übrigens hat diese Badewanne einfach ein
wpol
Effekt beende den Blog jetzt an dieser
Stelle auch wir gehen ins Bett und dann
sehen wir uns morgen wieder und danke
für euren ganzen Support ich lese alle
Kommentare dass euch das gerade total in
Weihnachtsstimmung bringt und dass das
eure Routine ist diese Vlogs gerade zu
gucken und ich wusste ja dass das jetzt
nicht der große Banger wird dass das
Aufrufzahlen wie von den
adventskalenderv Videos hat das sollte
es auch nie sein aber wir nehmen das
total gerne auf einfach als so eine
Zeitkapsel und wenn euch das noch
gefällt umso besser also vielen Dank und
bis morgen